okay why don't we go ahead and get
started let me uh welcome everyone to
our
thursday
uh noon conference or 11 30 conference
and uh today um
as as you may know one of our idl talks
where the uh the focus is on the
informatics discovery lab
and it actually gives me a great
pleasure to
introduce
an old friend of mine who we've probably
known each other about 15 years or so
and
we've kind of intersected in various
ways in the information retrieval world
and then java had started getting into
informatics so our paths have crossed in
in many ways
so
javed mostave is professor and director
of the carolina health informatics
program at the university of north
carolina
chapel hill i'll avoid making any
comments about academic
issues in north carolina
he's also a director of the laboratory
of applied informatics research deputy
director of the biomedical informatics
corps
of the translational clinical sciences
institute
their ctsa program
he's also co-founder and chief
scientific officer of keonah health in
chapel hill
also has
appointments at duke
prior to being at unc
he was at
indiana university where i think we
visited
when he was there as well
javed has a phd in information science
from the university of texas at austin
a masters
from ohio state university and a
bachelor of science from northwestern
oklahoma university so without further
ado i will turn it over to
chabad thank you thank you very much
can you all hear me
all right
so
yeah i i you know i i want to give you a
little bit of a background on this talk
bill and i have known each other 15
years but i've been working in the field
of information retrieval
probably about 20 years now
and i'm at a period where i'm beginning
to consolidate some of my work uh and
trying to develop
hopefully what would
become a manuscript for for a book
and with the focus on
sort of biomedical information as a
domain um and i'm trying to
use this opportunity to create a
overarching framework
to bring together my work so forgive me
if you feel like you're a guinea pig and
i'm sort of
using you as a as a way to share some of
my work
as i i
try to synthesize and develop a broad
framework
to kind of share how i view
basically information retrieval and the
major challenges in information
retrieval
my
if you want background information i i'm
just showing this to you
all of the work that i'm going to be
discussing goes back to this one article
um the multi-level approach to
intelligent information filtering
it's a pdf available
and then
more recently
i i published a editorial
called wither bioinformatics
sort of comparing
um sort of bench uh
wet lab
uh informatics
uh work kind of where you bring in
sequence data and you're
you know actually manipulating them
working with them versus
dry software oriented informatics work
where you don't touch the physical
specimen
and and where does the interface lie and
what's the role for bioinformatics in
that context how far can you push
science without touching the physical
specimen
without testing it in a lab
and this gives you some ideas about
the challenges and of informatics
as well and some of the ideas i'm going
to be sharing with you come from that
all right uh
see
so
the framework i'm calling a distributed
multi-level model
um
just as a way of background we kind of
all know this but to put this in context
of of the the volume of information
growth right
and this comes from the the
bioinformatics paper
um in terms of the growth going back to
we started with a about a hundred
billion
um
uh
you know uh
started with two two thousand base pair
but now we're at a hundred billion base
pairs doubling about every eighteen
months that kind of resembles another
model for growth in processing speed
that you're familiar with of computing
processing speed
there's been a nice paper recently on
just output of u.s healthcare system and
the data volume and the size of that
and they they estimated uh in
the in the last three years there was
about 150 exabytes of data and just as a
way to compare an exabyte is 10 to the
power of 18.
and there was an
estimate by how varian made a few years
ago
hal varian is the chief economist by the
way of google
who happens to be also an information
scientist
um is 160 exabytes
of total hard disk space in the world
and he has a couple of reports called
how much information is there in the
world
those are interesting analysis
but more importantly for us is the
volume of information the the growth of
information has implications of course
in terms of how we process and use that
information right
so
this comes from a nature genetics
paper which estimated that for certain
subfields like cell cycle
it's no longer possible for scientists
to read all the important papers in that
field
and there they plotted
the growth of literature output in in
those
certain specialized fields
and
that that has implications for us right
in terms of how we interact with
information retrieval systems and how we
just if we just go to pubmed and do a
search we may not be getting all the
relevant information that we need and
more importantly perhaps in the format
that we need
to be able to consume
i know this is a
bit busy let me just hone into this
so
variety of data and our problems and
challenges at different levels right
so we have
at the basic level we have biomedical
data
right
and the problem is we kind of
begin to provide access and retrieval
right here at this level but it needs to
be processed before interrogation and
interaction can happen
and these processing is where the action
is today
the entity detection
and association discovery and pattern
detection
and then interrogation and interaction
okay
my argument is if we create an
information retrieval model
we have to balance between
the challenges at this level in terms of
representing and processing the data
as well as the challenges of
interrogation and interaction
okay so it's a challenge of
data complexity with task complexity and
how do we balance those sides
just because we have intelligent ways of
processing doesn't mean we're done
there's a lot of challenges that come
and expectations and demands that come
from the user's perspective
that we have to also account for in our
model and it has to be
to be to be powerful it has to be robust
enough to be able to balance
so
on that theme
this is a classic information retrieval
model
okay
you have data that we aggregate we
organize we label put some metadata on
top and we have users creating and
interacting that data okay
this is a classic information retrieval
system
at least this view of pubmed is right
they give you a search box you're
supposed to put in some keywords
and
you know you get some retrieval
this is a little bit more advanced and
challenging information retrieval this
comes from a project that we are working
on and these are
data from a
publicly available medical records
called adne
i don't know how many of you have seen
acne data but
alzheimer's disease neuroimaging
initiative it's a really cool project
because they're making high quality
medical image data available publicly
available for research okay
but we need ways to manipulate access
interact with that data so this is this
is where the task and user requirements
come in as well
right
and
interestingly with complexity of data
the task requirements also obviously go
up right
this is ncbi
um data giving you you know human genome
sequence and you can hone in on specific
chromosomes and specific genes and find
related information to those
right
this is another view of information we
tend to think of information being in
one place but obviously
we all know information comes from
different places and they have to be
integrated information
you know to to create information
systems and retrieval systems we have to
assume
proper models and architectures have to
take into account that information is
always going to be distributed
you won't be able to silo everything we
don't want to silo everything right so
queries these are let's say
collections of information queries can
start in one place but information need
to be aggregated and brought to a single
place
right
in fact ncbi tries to do that
this is a ncbi
interface that integrates information
from multiple places and gives you
access through one interface
okay what happens in the background we
don't care probably we don't
really know but
that process of distributed silos and
information being integrated is taking
place
sometimes
we're not quitting
purposefully
we're not directly involved in the query
but the system is quitting for us
this is a snapshot from google news
which is if you read the f fine prints
if we can
look
the selection and placement of stories
on this page were determined
automatically
by a computer program
this whole thing was produced totally
automatically
so
the software
that is creating this
presentation for you
is an intelligent software some people
there are different names for these
types of software i call them agents
okay so agents
aggregate information from multiple
places based on some behavior or profile
of
your information need
creates a nice presentation and you can
always go in and modify your profile
but the system
does the heavy lifting if you will of
aggregating information okay this is an
operational running system imagine
having a system like this in healthcare
okay
i would love to have a system like this
for my research
that is always interrogating and
collecting information relevant to my
interest and creating a personalized
page for me automatically right
again the distributed nature of
information is behind the scene
that google news page has to interact
with multiple nodes
and if you look inside a node a node has
to do information representation and
classification
for it to prepare the information so
that information can be aggregated
intelligently
okay
so
if we take into those
uh sort of requirements if you will okay
and keep that in the in the background
where are we going so we know
the the
the fancy terms that we use today big
data
that big data by the way that that
problem has existed we're just naming it
and and creating it
calling it differently right if you will
you can think of this as big data
problem volume velocity heterogeneity
distributed nature of data
okay
but we have to i bring into this picture
of big data
of demand on that data the complexity of
tasks
it's not just
uh you know
a a solution is not going to be reached
if we just manage the integration and
classification and reorganization we
have to somehow
make those tasks and demands accommodate
the system for those tasks and demands
and anticipate some of them it can
happen at an individual user level
demand interacting with the system more
and more there is demand for people to
work together with information on
projects
that multiplies the complexity okay
so if we think of information retrieval
really it's a continuum we have we're
kind of over here
right now
user drives interaction looks for
information
you know organized does a lot of things
manually
but more we need to shift more and more
toward this direction as well because we
cannot physically
should not be involved in in doing a lot
of this heavy lifting manually
okay
and and this balancing
we'll always have to have
a human in the loop
but we also need the
intelligent systems
to be able to organize and represent and
classify for us okay
the shift in information retrieval
i can sort of look at the evolution of
it from three angles okay
you have
ir
classic ir
with hci human computer interaction
and
ai
artificial intelligence which really
contains in my view machine learning and
all these sort of
fancy things we do in a sort of
automated
classification representation if we take
a look at each of them
kind of
at a time the intersection we can look
for examples so ai and ir a lot of work
and machine learning in information
representation okay
ai and hci
user modeling customization
personalization
okay
hci ir interface design human computer
interaction i was telling aaron it's
kind of pleasant to see human computer
interaction
being recognized as increasingly a very
important area in medical biomedical
informatics and health informatics
and you know university of michigan is
recruiting so they put their prior
prioritization of the areas they're
interested in the top area they're
interested in is human computer
interaction another example i i'll give
i don't know if you guys noticed the
emea proceedings
had a page on the doctoral consortium
presentations
this year
and i looked at the background of the
doctoral students
of all of those that were invited
to do a doctoral
research presentation
100 percent where from
outside biomedical and health
informatics conventional
classical
biomedical health informatics programs
that was striking to me
they're all from high schools
and information schools
maybe their funding or model is
different i don't know
but the the influence of
sort of
information science and
hci in this field
i welcome it
but i think it needs to be accommodated
and and balanced in in an interesting
and and deliberate and reflective way
so
what are if i could summarize before i
present the model and some data and
results
so data diversity
dynamicity of the of the resources
content change fast
user needs tasks
wide variety of
of demands including visualization touch
high response
users interaction demand are not static
they change
okay
data in multiple locations highly
fragmented
uh under different policies and rules
so in summary those are our challenges
okay
so in terms of modeling this and looking
at it from a conceptual way how do we
build a system that can accommodate and
maybe balance among all of those
challenges okay so
we start by thinking of
this
environment as
in sort of three levels we have data
acquisition
our document acquisition
we have some processing taking place and
interaction
and look this is the only place that is
back and forth
the interaction is presentation and
access management
okay
there's a separate module that's
responsible for the ui and interaction
okay
and if we think of it as a distributed
model you have each of these boxes
interac in every node in every
collection interacting with each other
okay
so if the in this collection we need
information from here we interact with
the document access management module of
this environment to get the information
so on and so forth okay
and the goal is to go from data
documents images files etc
to
some notion of
relevance mapping
whatever the users need
and consider to be relevant
from
the
the resource
okay
and in terms of
again at abstraction level and i promise
i'm not going to show too many equations
or formulas
we're going from data to relevance
okay
broadly speaking we decompose or break
up the problem into i do this in sort of
two levels we have data
to organization or classification we
group or cluster or aggregate them in
meaningful groupings
and then
reason
about or identify
relevance based on those groups not
directly on the data
okay
we therefore reduce some complexity
a lot of complexity
when you when you want to find relevance
you find relevance in terms of data
groupings or clusters not in terms of
the individual data elements
okay
that is a cost also
we can we can discuss that later
so this is our broad level problem
we have two levels of decomposition
representation to grouping
some people who love machine learning
would call it classification okay
and the function two is from groups of
data
to
users
profiles or representations of means
it can be queries it could be standing
queries it could be different implicitly
collected data from users
google news
you know collects different ways of
understanding what you are interested in
it allows you explicitly to create a
profile but also use your cache
right to sort of look at your behavior
so
that level is at the final level of
interaction so we're really dealing with
two big levels here f1 and f2
this is our basic model
okay
this is the multi-level model
so if we take f1
there are some interesting problems that
we can isolate just at the data
representation and grouping level and
many of these problems are familiar to
you i'm sure you've heard about
entity detection
like finding protein names
accurately in large corpus
finding gene names accurately in large
noisy corpus
associating them in different ways genes
and proteins
or genes to diseases right
those are sort of entity detection
problems
then in the grouping level
we have different algorithms that do
grouping
depending on what you are after
unsupervised supervised i left out there
is actually a
hybrid one
called human in the loop
model
that is a in between unsupervised and
supervised you you can have a supervised
approach that keeps changing adapting
based on human input
okay
then there are problems associated with
at the representation level
heterogeneity of data
velocity of data
what you are grouping to the
classification groups
if you're grouping to mesh hierarchy how
dense is that hierarchy which part of
the hierarchy are you grouping to okay
let me
um now i'm going to begin to present
some some past research and i won't get
into too much detail in every one of
them but just to give you a flavor of of
things we've been doing but there's
there are threads of work here
for um that you can identify so we have
a we've been working on systems that do
entity detection
okay basically
if you give a large corpus
to these systems
they can find
gene names protein names and then find
protein chains or find associations or
emulate what human classifiers do like
you have mesh classification tree
we all know that's great but it's really
expensive
to to create mesh and maintain it right
and i love the fact that they do it and
i hope they continue doing it
but
we need ways to to to kind of do that
some of that work
automatically given you saw the curve
the volume of
data being produced the literature being
produced in different biomedical fields
to be able to identify
which topic is this uh document most
relevant to quickly without manual
intervention right
so we need systems that can help us
do this automatically so you know this
is this is the example of a system
called
vcgs vocabulary generation system
vocabulary and generation and
classification system and we
have this to experiment that when you
give a corpus can it find entities that
are meaningful and then can it can it
cluster those entities okay
and we've done some quite a bit of
research in this area so this paper is
in a a a representative paper
on protein name detection
it's an interesting paper in our view
because it combines a classic rule-based
approach for entity detection with
statistical approach
and created a hybrid approach
to
do
accurate protein name detection okay
here is another example
this is mesh classes this is
automatically produced classes
and we
are interested in this because we want
to see
how much we can emulate the mesh
hierarchy automatically without looking
at any dictionaries any curated sources
just based on
corpus that humans produce
okay
and we try to then evaluate the human
classification with automatic
classification okay
so
these are some results these have been
published already if you
search under my name i have citations
for some of them we're comparing
automatic with
mesh
accuracy but in this case we're
comparing
the utility of automatically produced
classification versus mesh
classification in filtering
documents
so when documents come in we classify
them using automated we classify them
using the mesh and then we compare the
the two classifications to a human
profile
of interest they are interested in and
see how accurate they are in terms of
filtering through that human profile
okay we're not really interested in
winning against the human
classification
i would be very happy if we
closely correlate with human
classification if we come even close
okay because we would have then have
some confidence in the system okay
so this this was done this work was done
using
unsupervised classification and
clustering
there's an algorithm called maximin
that's doesn't require any training
okay basically it does it on its own it
generates the classes you use the
classes and then you classify okay
whereas
there is another paper
another research we've done
where we compared
supervised classification
so this is the result from neural net
classification
okay
with uh baseline
uh human classification and neural net
classification we compared results of
accuracy and then filtering recall
precision
okay
of course neural net supervised
classification does better than
unsupervised
because
it's it's trained manually you trade it
on data that is good data and you can
bring the the results closer
uh to
to a
automated classification approach we
also compared filtering performances
okay
let me see
i have to go a little faster i apologize
but just to give you a flavor of the
types of work involved at the
representation classification level
these days you hear about data streams
you know volume of data and how quickly
you can process them
so we've done some work on data streams
so the idea was to subject a
information retrieval system to
different stream sizes different sets of
data and we we've experimented with you
know 10 20 40 but this can be scaled of
course
and we also experimented with
classification gra granularity number of
classes you are classifying two
and what we were trying to do to see if
an automated system that is doing the
classification automatically
can it one do the classification
consistently well even when the stream
sizes increases
can it do well even when the
classification complexity increases the
span size of classification hierarchy
increases okay and how does that
behavior
impact
average precision okay
as you for example in this data
we're showing that when the stream size
is 40
the uh the actually the error rate
um
sorry the the standard deviation begins
drops significantly when it's 40
standard deviation in terms of
performance across classes
okay average precision across all the
classes and
the performance therefore across classes
were pretty consistent
uh eve when the uh the uh stream size
was pretty large
i don't want to bombard bombard you with
a lot of data but i do want to give you
a flavor of and and by the way obviously
none of these threads of research
are finished you know there are many
different parameters to study under each
of these threads this the
volume of data and its impact on
retrieval okay
again because data is dynamic you can't
predict who will put what data in what
collection when
and how often is that collection going
to change how is that going to impact my
retrieval
okay
and then my retrieval is dependent on
how data is organized that means the
classification of that data if that
classification is simple versus complex
how is that going to impact my retrieval
okay so as classification span increases
what happens to the system one thing i'm
not sharing with you is the internal
details of the system
which matters of course
because the internal
system
has to be robust enough to adapt to
growing
size of stream and growing complexity of
the classification right what we tried
to actually these papers got published
not because of the novelty of the
problem per se
but because of the novelty of the system
to adapt to changes such dynamicity okay
i i want to give you a flavor of image
data because i think that's a really
it's an area that needs more focus from
biomedical informatics
all you have to do is look at the past
few issues of jamia and see how many
papers have been published on imaging
informatics
uh not many uh we can do so much more in
that field and now that we have data
sets
to be able to really
good data sets to be able to study
problems
we should be able to do more interesting
work with image data
so this is a
series of
slides on our project called viewfinder
viewfinder
medicine
vfm
and what we're trying to do is basically
uh
if you have
mr
or ct scans
and you know the process that they go
through for annotation before a
clinician can look at them there's a
whole you know workflow involved right
it's a bit controversial because you
know the clinicians want a very careful
analysis and annotation by experts
before they
review these images right
but that process is very time consuming
and expensive
okay
and we're not suggesting that we're
going to illuminate that process but
what if someone walks in and does a ct
scan or does an mr and and the physician
wants to quickly go in and browse those
scans
and be able to
uh interrogate those scans while they're
being annotated maybe right and one of
the one of the projects we what we're
interested in is to create such a
browser
okay with very minimal annotation
okay
and the idea is if i select a case or a
patient
and this interface the the guiding
principle for for it it's called fisheye
display that is if you put something in
the center that's your query that's the
center of attention everything else gets
retrieved based on the characteristics
of this image or this case so i have a
unknown case
of someone's ct or mr
they may or may not have alzheimer's
okay
what i want to do is quickly find if
there are other patients in a cohort
potentially
that are similar to this patient
that have been fully annotated that have
been analyzed already okay
so that i can begin to get grasp and get
an idea of this case while i wait for
the full annotation to be done okay
that's that's the that's the purpose of
this project
let's see
i i have some by the way i'm happy to
share
the details of the uh the algorithm
and how we're doing this we've published
this already um so this is the
representation algorithm
okay we're doing very basic things like
from a stack of scans we select the
central scans that we think are the most
important to do the representation on
because we don't want to do it on all
the scans
then we do some cropping we do
segmentation
gray fluid white matter segmentation we
represent the data using a matrix
representation
and we apply some compression on it
reduce and summarize that image into a
single matrix
and the interesting work i think in my
view is combining the visual features
with the textual features using a
multi-normal regression model
we actually create a single
representation for visual and textual
representation
then we do classification by the way for
image classification for mr and ct if
anyone is getting into it
is a support vector machine svm
approach is really powerful and people
have tried this and have already gotten
very good results
so before you invent your own please
look at some of these
papers
then we do ranking using euclidean
distance
where we take in the classification
weighting into consideration
then we do measures of classification
accuracy
and you know some of the parameters
we're interested in is how many slices
in the central centrality parameter work
best
we also take into account
let's see
any other parameters we played around
here here we are only looking at
centrality slices for our classification
accuracy turns out surprisingly we don't
need that many slices here to get the
best classification
if you take more slices it doesn't
necessarily give you better
classification accuracy
then we look at ranking
based on equity we compare the query
with the classified images
and we do ranking at different precision
level if we
take a look at the top 50 top 40 top 30
top 20 top 10 obviously precision
increases as you lower the number
precision cutoff level right
and remember in this first display we
don't need that many images to to stack
around that central image so precision
at 10 if it's pretty high that's pretty
good result
okay
by the way
mro ct classification for alzheimer's is
almost at near 90 accuracy level already
using svm
so if you get 91 or 92 you're still fine
you can publish that
um
the fun stuff i guess is beyond
classification that is at the level of
ui development and user interfaces okay
and we're doing quite a bit of work
there
and my approach is
i'm i'm driven by
not just the user complexity and task
complexity i want to understand also how
the information is represented
and how
the
behind the interface the challenge of
driving interaction and driving dynamic
interaction
change the organization and architecture
of the system itself so
these papers really introduce this
modeling approach for user profiles so
we don't just get a static profile and
say that's it the profile is adapted
dynamically
based on user's interaction with the
system and the dynamic adaptation is
done probabilistically over categories
of data so we get data or documents
categorize them learn the model the user
model and then use this to prioritize
and present information this is based on
a machine learning approach called
reinforcement learning
okay
by the way
i'm really
i know
that there's a lot more exciting work
that can be done with not just machine
learning but with this term that i
used a few times machine learning with
human in the loop
and this is going to be it's already big
it'll become even more interesting and
challenging and will create many more i
think uh
interesting systems
where
the machine has a task of automating
predicting what's relevant to you but as
you interact as you even enter the
environment it already knows something
about you
and it can take that into account to re
rank and customize the information
okay
um
so reinforcement learners are are those
types of algorithms okay
the types of projects i did in this
space is simulating
different types of contacts different
types of user behavior
can you guess why did i simulate why
didn't i engage people to do these types
of studies
like you know people change their mind
right
or
their interests change over time and
different patterns
why did i have to use simulation
because you can't force that
you can't have people in your lab and
say use my system
and then you know at some point just
change your mind
or
you know just be fickle today
don't be too consistent
so that that's and i'm pressing this
button because uh we we want the
audience to be able to hear but um
you know that i mean i'm glad you're i
was wondering whether you're gonna when
you were gonna bring the user into this
situation you know because um you know
as you know one one of the um
uh challenges with evaluating
information retrieval is we kind of
assume that every user is generic and we
know that people are different and we
know that people you know sometimes
sometimes i'm just looking for a single
document that i know exists and i don't
want any system to get in my way to keep
me from doing that that's right um you
know other times i'm interested in more
general things sometimes interested in
more focused right things right so those
are wide problems still
i think you'll be happy to know that
there aren't really
uh one system that i can say it does you
know a great job uh in terms of
predicting
you know what you are after what i can
tell you though current systems even the
best of them are really bad
maybe you expect me to say that but
google is bad in terms of supporting
research
you know why
because it's very poor in recall
it doesn't find all the best articles
in a domain it finds the top
five or six articles that it thinks are
important to you even at that
right google is engineered to be high
precision machine
okay
so if you're interested in a topic like
bill said that you want to go in and
explore and you don't know yet exactly
what facet interests you
we don't have good retrieval systems for
those
types of problem okay
um
and you know
predicting people's interest is a is a
really difficult problem and
i'm not suggesting simulation is the
only way but it's it's one of the ways
you can begin to study
how different types of interest affect
retrieval systems and their performances
so you know this is precision on one
side number of sessions
and you have interest level that i
purposefully manipulated i changed you
know so you start here you have concrete
interest sort of
middle to concrete
not very sure about what i'm interested
in
how does the system behave okay
over over a period of time
and then people change their mind they
start with low interest
go to high interest over time as they
use the system or they start with high
interest in some topics or categories
and then their interest drops how does
the system
behave in that context right in terms of
its performance of predicting
the best interest to you even when you
are changing your mind
from session to session
okay
i have to hurry a bit
so i've also looked at visualization
i've looked at different types of ways
of understanding user behavior
we've we've built a system this is
a system called met sifter
so where we studied different types of
interest patterns
captured by the system the easiest way
is to do equity right
you tell the system what you're
interested in
what if you want the system to learn
based on what documents you look at what
do you read how long you spend on one
topic versus the other that's implicit
way of learning your interest so we
compared explicit implicit combined when
the system kind of predicts what you're
interested in it has a profile
it has a profile of it thinks that heart
attack and high blood pressure is what
you're interested in
what if i allow the user to go in and
change it
so that's a hybrid model
so we this study we did with with people
subjects and we tried to predict
different
to see
over a period of time what happens to
performance and we use these are
standard measures by the way as you know
recall precision to predict right
another
thread of research which i think is
really important is we're all excited
about visualization
but most visualization i'll just tell
you simply a visualization is so great
right we all love visualization what is
the production grade system today that
actually uses visualization
like why doesn't google use
visualization
you should think about these things a
bit sometimes you know there's so much
money and effort being expended
because google processes what is it
something like 40 million queries a day
and and every cycle matters so every
feature they think about implementing
has to be
scalable exactly
scalability is a major challenge
and we can all get excited about
beautiful pictures
this is where this is
this is how i look at
information retrieval is you shouldn't
just look at the the the modality of
presentation you should also think about
what it takes to support that modality
doesn't matter how powerful this
modality is if you don't deal with what
it takes to support the modality
it's not going to be scalable
you won't be able to put it in
production systems
and you have to
properly you should think about both
challenges at the same time
so in information retrieval there's a
very
i think pretty important thread of
research called scattergather
marty hurst who is well known in
information visualization field
hearst
h-e-r-s she's a professor at uc berkeley
she had done with some colleagues in
xerox a while back
some research on information
visualization and retrieval if we
present information in visually
powerful meaningful semantically
relevant ways how does that impact
interaction okay
but we subjected that research to this
test that okay you're presenting
information as clusters is it scalable
okay what if we scale the information
like increase the size of the collection
can i still do visualization using your
approach answer was no okay because the
complexity if you look at the clustering
complexity of the original scatter
gather algorithm that's on square
sorry the
n square didn't come out well there
that's a large complexity okay
so how can i create a visualization
approach that's scalable and can still
cluster and present information in an
interesting meaningful way so this study
sort of engaged in that
and
we're interested in efficiency
scalability
we're also interested in and i'll tell
you the trick that we did it's really a
trick and we're not very proud of it
we're going to try to improve it trick
is to break the clustering into two
halves
do the hierarchical clustering offline
capture the clusters
and then use that clustering information
online for to support interaction so
don't do clustering online which is
very challenging to do okay
but can you combine this offline online
way in a in a way that still supports
interaction
and scattergather is really interesting
you should look at it if you're
interested in visualization and we also
looked at efficiency effectiveness in
side by side okay
finally the one last thing i will do
this is this is a real
this is more of our recent work on
distributed information retrieval okay
the challenge here is
we know information is distributed
so if i start a query here and the
information is over here how fast can i
find it
and what's the effectiveness and
efficiency of that search okay
so
broadly speaking from an intuitive
perspective what we did is we applied
something called network level
clustering are sometimes called semantic
overlay
and this borrows from some work by
kleinberg particularly
so the idea is to cluster at collection
level and create links
among
the collections that have some common
information so if i'm look if i start a
query in one collection it's not there i
want to find the next node i want to
find the node that has some similarity
to this node
so i need to build semantic overlay or
collect collection level
network level
ties or links okay
so to do clustering at network level you
can apply different techniques
and there's a very interesting phenomena
called clustering paradox
and what that what that means is if you
cluster
too much
among the networks
nodes
you would lose ties to
across network across nodes
okay
if you don't cluster too much if you're
at a very low weak level semantic
overlay you'll have random connections
all over
okay
it is therefore important to maintain
some weak ties but also have strong ties
okay
what's that balance
clustering therefore has a kind of a
trade-off
so this describes the problem so i have
a a query i want to find uh you know
arlene chang's
research area at unc that's the her main
web page is what i'm after
and i start a query at a at a network
node the system has to now
uh interrogate other nodes to find
arlene's
website okay
totally in a distributed way there is no
centralized index to consult okay
basically i start from a node and i look
at semantically closed nodes which i
have clustered before right and i asked
the neighbors do you have the page no
who is your semantically closed node i
go to that one and ask that note so on
and so forth until i figure out where
the web page is okay
this is by the way actually supported
by a data set from cmu
called clue web
that has 50 million web pages
okay supports three million websites you
can simulate a very large network
using that data set okay
so if i want to find a sales faculty
members page started using the system it
has to end up here
okay
so we did some studies especially on the
clustering exponent that is the semantic
overlay how closely clustered they are
how how
weakly clustered they are
and
just to summarize and we looked at these
standard metrics precision f measures
number of hops okay search time
and
we looked at different types of
algorithms
just based on similarity
just doing a random walk
just doing a degree search like all the
search all the connections
or combine similarity with the
connections
and turns out like for one approach
similarity search this was published
last year this is my most recent sort of
comprehensive work with a doctoral
student
this is the clustering paradox
performance starts up really high as you
as you increase the clustering exponent
you're clustering more more and more
closely
the performance drops and then it starts
to pick up again
it's kind of
uh interesting phenomena
i will stop here i don't want to
overload you with a lot of different
types of data but the distributed search
is also
is a big area in our field and it'll
it's just beginning to be explored
and there are lots of challenges there
we can't all nothing against google i
love google
but we can't obviously all rely on
central indexes to serve our information
retrieval needs
okay
thank you very much
questions yes
so as far as visualization combined with
search do you think the main problem is
scalability as you said or is the
problem at least from google's point of
view that they haven't figured out a
visualization that actually adds value
to their vast amount of generic users
that you know i wonder if a significant
part of the problem is the fact that you
know google is kind of for everybody and
that kind of means it's specifically for
nobody and while in particular domains
a particular kind of visualization could
have a high value there may not be at
least it's not obvious to me what the
visualization would be for everybody and
so they haven't thrown all their
computing power at it which they could
probably solve
if you know it was going to bring them
more eyeballs and more users and more
revenue right now scalability is a major
challenge with visualization
techniques because they do require more
analysis
of data beforehand as well as if you
want to provide more steerable
visualization like
you know some of the searching that they
have now
actually learns from the past queries
that you recently did right
incorporating those types of functions
in visualized representation of
information is even more challenging
but to answer your question of course
it's partly driven from economical
concerns
if there were
a lot of value to provide certain types
of visualization for certain communities
of users
they probably would have expended and
found more hybrid approaches like we did
and begin to expose google has a very
interesting project on image search
which is in beta
where you can use an image to find
related images
i know they're working on other sort of
frontier uh projects you know i use that
to find so what i do sometimes is i'm
walking in a garden i see this unknown
tree or a flower
and i love it and i want to include it
in my backyard so i take a picture i
actually did that brought home uploaded
it searched using that picture to found
to find other
similar flowers and then linked from
that to see which gardener or garden
shop offers it okay
if they can figure out the business
model maybe for certain types of
communities we would get more advanced
but
there is a very big problem with the
google model
which is having one entity one
organization
index and organize all the information
like you said it ends up being not
relevant for specific types of user
communities and groups it ends up
serving a very broad group of users
right
so there's a question from the twitter
feed from kate baltalis who's one of our
online master's students who's actually
a librarian by training yeah and is
asking and of course this is the
limitation of twitter
140 characters but how would you best
train people to gather relevant medical
information from computers
ischools library schools notoriously bad
at that
right
how do you collect information from
i i i think i hope anyways that she's
getting at um you know how do you you
know you can serve people the right
documents right um but you know how are
you actually communicating and there was
once a study that that i did where we
actually showed that people found the
answer to the question in the document
but still answered the question wrong
you know so how do you um you know is
that within the
domain of what you're looking at
uh
i i love the idea of of having
interesting and useful
ways of engaging humans in the loop
of search not just to improve machine
learning
but to improve information services
i think it has a very basic i would
answer it as a very basic human approach
which is
get to know your users well
and work with them
maybe become their collaborators in
their research projects
that's the way to serve research needs
and really come up with
good answers
for information needs
and you know beyond that there are so
many other layers and levels of services
i can think of you know that we can
create obviously to capture needs and to
to encourage your users to engage with
you
and
we can we can create different types of
mechanisms for that
a little past the hour so thank you for
presenting this i hope our feedback is
helpful thank you
you